لقد كنت أشعر بالحزن، كنت أشعر
بالقلق، كنت أشعر بالقلق، هذه هي الطريقة التي يقول بها الجبهة الإسلامية للإنقاذ بدير إنه
وآخرون يشعرون بأنهم
أمريكيون فلسطينيون كمسلمين وكطلاب في
جامعة ستانفورد، إنه أمر مخيف أن هذا
النوع من الكراهية يمكن أن يحدث  في مكان من
المفترض أن أشعر فيه بالخوف في بيتي
نتيجة لما يعتقد أنها
جرائم كراهية، يقوم قسم
السلامة العامة بالجامعة الآن بالتحقيق في خمس
حوادث منذ بداية
حرب حماس على إسرائيل، يبدو أن أربعة منها استهدفت
الطلاب العرب بينما  تم الإبلاغ عن إحداها على أنها أعمال
تخريب معادية للسامية، وهي أحدث
حادثة جريمة كراهية محتملة حدثت يوم
الجمعة، وتقول الجامعة إنها كانت حادثة
اختباء وهروب واضحة شارك فيها
طالب عربي مسلم في الحرم الجامعي، ومن الصعب
فهم إمكانية حدوث ذلك،
والمشكلة هي  لا
يمكن أن يحدث ذلك فحسب، بل أصبح الآن واقعًا علينا
جميعًا أن نتعايش معه. في
بيان تقول الجامعة إن جامعة
ستانفورد تعتبر الأعمال المعادية للعرب والمعادية
للإسلام، قبل أن
تقول الجامعة أيضًا إن السائق قد
أجرى اتصالاً بصريًا مع
تسارعت الضحية وصدمت
الضحية ثم ابتعدت عنها بينما كانت
تصرخ "تحيا لك ولأفرادك من
النافذة السفلية للمركبة، وحقيقة
أنها تحولت بسرعة كبيرة بالفعل إلى
شيء بهذا الحجم هو أمر
مخيف مرة أخرى، وشملت الحوادث الأخرى
مجموعة من الطلاب".  التعرض للدفع
والبصق على الطالب ودهس شخص
ما لحقيبة تحتوي على جهاز كمبيوتر وأشياء ثمينة
أخرى،
لا ينبغي أن يكون لما يحدث في الخارج تأثير على صحة
وحياة الطلاب في الحرم الجامعي في
بلد يبعد آلاف الأميال
أفادت الحادثة المعادية للسامية بإزالة موزة
تزين باب طالب يهودي
من مسكنهم في
بيان قالت المدرسة إن إزالة
رمز ديني مقدس تعتبر
شكلاً من أشكال الترهيب الذي يستهدف
الجالية اليهودية بشكل عام والمجموعات التي
تمثل الطلاب من كلا الجانبين  يقولون
إنهم قلقون بشأن هذه الحوادث
ويقول الطلاب مثل بدير إنهم قلقون
بشأن المستقبل، علينا أن نكون في حالة
تأهب دائمًا، علينا أن نكون على
حافة الهاوية دائمًا، ومن المرهق أن
نراقب من فوق كتفنا 247
ولا تزال السلطات تبحث عن
المشتبه به في  أخبرني الجري الخفي الذي
يعتقد أنه كان يقود سيارة تويوتا
فورنر الآن فيما يتعلق بالضحية الذي
لا يزال في المستشفى أنه
غير مستعد لإجراء مقابلة أمام الكاميرا لكنه
قال إنه يريد الدعوة إلى حب
التفاهم والشمول مع
الطلاب الآخرين.  الذين أخبروني أنهم
يوافقون على هذه الرسالة ويؤيدونها ولكنهم
أيضًا يشعرون بقلق بالغ